There are other ways we could have noticed this important feature
of the data set. But, there are also other ways, that
by jumping into a different analysis, we might have missed this.
For example, if we just look at a five number summary
of the data, we might not notice this so easily. One
clue to the discreteness is that the 75th percentile is the
same as the maximum. We could also see this discreteness by
looking at how many distinct prices there are in the data set.
So here it looks like there's about 20 different prices.
Tabling the variable we get an idea of the distribution
like we saw in the histogram. So now that we
know something about the price, let's figure out on a given
purchase occasion how many eight ounce yogurts does a household
purchase. To answer this we need to combine accounts of
the different yogurt flavors into one variable. For example, for
this particular household, on one purchase occasion, they bought three different
types of yogurt. To figure this out for all the households,
we need to make use of a new function. The function
is called the transform function. Now I haven't introduced this function
yet, but I want you to look up the function and run
the examples of the code at the bottom of the documentation
to figure out what it does. See if you can create
a new variable called all.purchases, which gives the total counts of
yogurt for each observation or household purchase. Keep in mind that you
need to save this variable to the data frame,
so this may or may not be in your syntax.